Add a pop of culture to every room in your house with SiriusXM. Stream over 425 channels of ad-free music, plus exclusive talk, world-class news, live play-by-play sports, comedy, and popular podcasts with the SXM app. Subscribe to the streaming platinum plan and get your first three months for free. Visit SiriusXM.ca for details. SiriusXM, everything you want to hear, lives here. Our episodes deal with SiriusXM and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre.
通过 SiriusXM 为您家中的每个房间增添一抹文化气息。使用 SXM 应用程序，您可以畅享 425 个以上的无广告音乐频道，以及独家谈话节目、世界级新闻、现场体育赛事直播、喜剧和热门播客。订阅流媒体白金套餐，即可免费获得前三个月的服务。详情请访问 SiriusXM.ca。SiriusXM，您想听的一切，尽在于此。我们的剧集涉及 SiriusXM 以及经常令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。
For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The Station 61 crew of the Omaha Fire Department were just over an hour into their shift on Saturday, August 17, 2013, when they were called out to a house fire two miles south. Within a matter of seconds, the firefighters had pulled on their safety equipment, raced to their truck, and left the station. They reached the address five minutes later, arriving at 8.20am. The split-level home sat on a quiet street with a small front yard.
如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。2013 年 8 月 17 日星期六，奥马哈消防局 61 号站的队员们刚开始值班一个多小时，就接到通知，前往两英里外的一处火灾现场。几秒钟内，消防员们穿好安全装备，冲向消防车，离开了车站。五分钟后，他们到达了该地址，时间是上午 8 点 20 分。这座错层式住宅坐落在一条安静的街道上，前面有一个小院子。
The fire inside was already extinguished, having burnt itself out naturally. Inside, the house was smoldering and the air was thick with smoke. The walls had turned black with soot, and its furnishings were charred beyond repair. But, there were no embers or flames remaining, and all of the surfaces were cooled to the touch. It had been some time since the house was ablaze. As the firefighters conducted a thorough search of the property, they discovered something else.
屋内的火势已经熄灭，是自然燃尽的。屋内烟雾弥漫，空气浑浊。墙壁被烟灰熏黑，家具烧焦得无法修复。但是，没有余烬或火焰，所有表面摸起来都是凉的。房子着火已经有一段时间了。当消防员对房产进行彻底搜查时，他们发现了别的东西。
There had been several fatalities. Meanwhile, an email sat unopened in the inbox of 36-year-old Dave Krupa. It had been sent more than eight hours earlier at 11.57pm on Friday, August 16. If Dave had clicked on the email, he would have been met with a disturbing claim. I am not lying, I set that nasty whore's house on fire, the message read. I hope the whore and her kids die in it. Dave Krupa had been out of the dating scene for more than a decade when he suddenly found himself single again.
发生了几起死亡事件。与此同时，36 岁的戴夫·克鲁帕（Dave Krupa）的收件箱里有一封未读邮件。它是在 8 月 16 日星期五晚上 11 点 57 分发出的，距今已超过八小时。如果戴夫点击了这封邮件，他会看到一个令人不安的说法。邮件写道：“我没有撒谎，我放火烧了那个下贱婊子的房子。我希望那个婊子和她的孩子死在里面。”戴夫·克鲁帕在结束上一段恋情后，已经有十多年没有涉足约会圈了，直到他突然发现自己又单身了。
After 12 years together, he and Amy Flora, the mother of his two children, had decided to split when they realised that they wanted different things. Dave was eager to get out there and start seeing new people, but he wasn't ready for anything serious. He'd spent most of his adult life in a committed relationship, and here was a chance to have a bit of fun. One day in October of 2012, Dave was working behind the counter of the auto repair shop where he was an assistant manager when a woman walked in and immediately caught his eye.
在在一起 12 年后，他和两个孩子的母亲艾米·弗洛拉（Amy Flora）意识到他们想要的东西不同，决定分手。戴夫渴望走出去，开始结识新朋友，但他还没准备好开始一段认真的关系。他成年后的大部分时间都在一段稳定的关系中度过，而现在是一个享受一点乐趣的机会。2012 年 10 月的一天，戴夫正在他担任助理经理的汽车修理店柜台后面工作，这时一位女士走了进来，立刻吸引了他的目光。
She was 37-year-old Carrie Fava and had brought in her black Ford Explorer for a minor repair. Dave felt a mutual spark of attraction but was reluctant to do anything about it. Being a customer out didn't seem professional. A few days later, he was scrolling through profiles on a dating website when Carrie's photo suddenly popped up. Now he knew for sure she was single and looking to meet someone. Dave typed a brief message to Carrie that read, Hi, I know you. Then he hit send.
她是 37 岁的凯莉·法瓦（Carrie Fava），她把她的黑色福特探险者开来做小修理。戴夫感到了一种相互吸引的火花，但又不想采取任何行动。约会顾客似乎不太专业。几天后，当他在约会网站上浏览个人资料时，凯莉的照片突然弹了出来。现在他确定她是单身，并且想结识某人。戴夫给凯莉发了一条简短的信息：“嗨，我认识你。”然后他点击了发送。
Carrie sent a polite reply back and a couple of weeks later she returned to Dave's work to have something else fixed with her car. This time, Dave made his move. The pair exchanged phone numbers and made plans to see each other soon. Dave and Carrie's first date was on October 29 at an Applebee's restaurant. They hit it off right away while both agreeing that they weren't looking for anything committed or serious. They went home together that night and soon they were spending more and more time together.
凯莉回了一条礼貌的回复，几周后她回到戴夫的工作地点修理汽车的其他问题。这一次，戴夫采取了行动。两人交换了电话号码，并计划很快见面。戴夫和凯莉的第一次约会是在 10 月 29 日，地点是一家 Applebee's 餐厅。他们一见如故，同时都同意他们不想寻找任何承诺或认真的关系。那天晚上他们一起回家，很快他们在一起的时间就越来越多了。
After a couple of weeks, things were comfortable enough for Dave to make an unconventional offer. Dave lived on his own in an apartment in Omaha, Nebraska. He'd moved to the city to be closer to his children who lived just across the Iowa State border in his ex-partner's hometown of Council Bluffs. Carrie lived in Iowa as well, but her small town of Macedonia was an hours' drive from the IT company in Omaha where she worked as a computer programmer. From Monday, November 12, Carrie was required to work late hours on a week-long project,
几周后，情况变得足够舒适，戴夫提出了一个非传统的提议。戴夫独自住在内布拉斯加州奥马哈的一间公寓里。他搬到这座城市是为了离他的孩子们更近，孩子们住在爱荷华州边界对面的前伴侣家乡康瑟尔布拉夫斯。凯莉也住在爱荷华州，但她居住的马其顿小镇距离她担任计算机程序员的奥马哈 IT 公司有一个小时的车程。从 11 月 12 日星期一开始，凯莉需要为一个为期一周的项目加班，
so Dave suggested that she stay with him until she'd met her deadline. That way, she wouldn't have to worry about a long commute to and from work. Carrie was happy with this plan and packed her bags to stay with Dave from that Monday on. It was mid-morning on Tuesday, November 13 when Dave heard his phone ding. It was a text message from Carrie that read, let's move in together. Dave was taken aback. They'd only been dating for two weeks and he'd been clear that he wasn't looking for
所以戴夫建议她在他那里住，直到她完成截止日期。这样，她就不必担心往返工作的漫长通勤了。凯莉对这个计划很满意，收拾好行李从那个周一开始和戴夫住在一起。11 月 13 日星期二上午，戴夫听到手机响了。那是凯莉发来的一条短信，写着：“我们住在一起吧。”戴夫大吃一惊。他们才约会了两周，而且他已经明确表示他不想寻找
a commitment. Perhaps inviting Carrie to stay with him for a whole week had given her the wrong message. He tapped out a reply explaining to Carrie that he wasn't interested in her suggestion. Within seconds, Dave's phone dinged again. Carrie responded, Fine, fuck you, I'm seeing somebody else, don't contact me again, I hate you, go away. Repulsed and annoyed, Dave put his phone away. He'd thought Carrie was better than that.
任何承诺。也许邀请凯莉和他住一周给了她错误的信号。他敲出一条回复，向凯莉解释说他对她的建议不感兴趣。几秒钟内，戴夫的手机又响了。凯莉回复道：“好吧，去你妈的，我在和别人约会，别再联系我了，我恨你，滚开。”戴夫感到厌恶和恼火，把手机收了起来。他原以为凯莉比这更好。
Later on, he ventured about the situation to some of his colleagues who were empathetic and shared their own bad dating stories. When Dave returned home that night, Carrie had already packed up her things and left. He told himself now that she'd shown her true colours, he'd definitely dodged a bullet. A couple of days passed and Dave moved on, focusing on work instead. It appeared that Carrie had moved on as well. Then, all of a sudden, he was hit by a barrage of angry text messages from her. One after another, they lit up on his phone.
后来，他向一些同事倾诉了这种情况，他们表示同情并分享了他们自己糟糕的约会故事。当戴夫那天晚上回到家时，凯莉已经收拾好东西离开了。他告诉自己，既然她露出了真面目，他肯定躲过了一劫。几天过去了，戴夫继续前进，转而专注于工作。凯莉似乎也继续前进了。然后，突然之间，他遭到了她一连串愤怒短信的轰炸。一条接一条，它们在他的手机上亮起。
Carrie told Dave she was furious and started insulting and abusing him. Occasionally, she tried calling, but Dave refused to pick up. Day after day, the abuse continued. Dave struggled to go about his normal life as the constant notifications on his phone interrupted his shifts at work and his social activities afterwards. Dave's email inbox was also flooded with a series of aggressive messages which seemed to grow increasingly hostile and nonsensical. Some were downright disturbing.
凯莉告诉戴夫她很愤怒，并开始侮辱和虐待他。偶尔，她试图打电话，但戴夫拒绝接听。日复一日，虐待仍在继续。戴夫努力过正常的生活，因为手机上不断的通知打断了他的工作班次和之后社交活动。戴夫的电子邮件收件箱也被一系列攻击性信息淹没，这些信息似乎变得越来越敌对和荒谬。有些简直令人不安。
One featured the subject line watching. Carrie claimed to be observing Dave's movements and she sometimes attached photos she'd taken of his home and car. One day, Carrie started calling Dave's work and hanging up each time someone answered. For an entire day, the auto repair shop's phone was tied up with hundreds of these prank calls, preventing customers from getting through, interrupting everyone's workday and infuriating Dave's boss and co-workers. Dave almost lost his job over the incident.
其中一封的主题是“监视”。凯莉声称在观察戴夫的行踪，有时还会附上她拍摄的他的家和车的照片。有一天，凯莉开始给戴夫的工作单位打电话，每次有人接听就挂断。整整一天，汽车修理店的电话都被数百个恶作剧电话占线，导致客户无法打入，打断了每个人的工作日，并激怒了戴夫的老板和同事。戴夫差点因为这件事丢了工作。
Dave was stunned. He had never experienced anything like this. Finding himself the target of a non-stop harassment campaign was incredibly distressing. But to Dave's horror, he wasn't the only one that Carrie had set her sights on. Carrie's rage at being rejected by Dave prompted her to go after others in his life, specifically other women who he'd been romantically involved with. Carrie's ex Amy Flora, who'd been Dave's partner for more than a decade, was on the receiving end of Carrie's anger.
戴夫惊呆了。他从未经历过这样的事情。发现自己成为一场不间断骚扰运动的目标令人难以置信地痛苦。但令戴夫恐惧的是，他并不是凯莉盯上的唯一一个人。凯莉因被戴夫拒绝而产生的愤怒促使她去追逐他生活中的其他人，特别是他曾经有过浪漫关系的女性。戴夫的前任艾米·弗洛拉（Amy Flora），曾是戴夫十多年的伴侣，成为了凯莉愤怒的承受者。
Carrie also targeted another woman named Liz Golia, who Dave had been seeing casually. Carrie was aware of Liz after bumping into her one night at Dave's apartment. In text to Dave, Carrie called Liz, quote, a fat ugly whore. One day, not long after the harassment began, Dave received a call from Liz who sounded upset and confused. She told him Carrie had started texting and emailing her, and Liz wanted to know how Carrie had gotten her contact details. Things became even scarier when Liz returned home one day to find that the garage of her
凯莉还针对另一位名叫利兹·戈利亚（Liz Golia）的女性，戴夫曾与她随意交往。凯莉在一天晚上在戴夫的公寓撞见利兹后就知道了她。在给戴夫的短信中，凯莉称利兹为“一个肥胖丑陋的婊子”。有一天，在骚扰开始后不久，戴夫接到了利兹的电话，她听起来很不安和困惑。她告诉他凯莉开始给她发短信和邮件，利兹想知道凯莉是怎么得到她的联系方式的。当利兹有一天回到家发现她的车库被闯入时，事情变得更加可怕了。
split-level rental house had been broken into. The thief had stolen some checks Liz kept in there. Then, on November 23, Liz entered her garage to see a nasty message scrawled on the wall in spray paint. It read, Hore from Dave. Both Liz and Dave subsequently received an email from Carrie in which she bragged about having committed the vandalism.
那个小偷偷走了利兹放在那里的几张支票。然后，在 11 月 23 日，利兹走进她的车库，看到墙上用喷漆潦草地写着一条恶毒的信息。上面写着：“来自戴夫的婊子。”随后，利兹和戴夫都收到了凯莉的一封电子邮件，她在邮件中吹嘘自己实施了这次破坏行为。
And that Carrie now knew where she lived, Liz filed a report with the Omaha Police Department. Police officers weren't able to track Carrie down as she quit her job for a new role in Kansas, but some digging into her background revealed that she'd been diagnosed with bipolar disorder some years earlier. According to Carrie's mother, she had previously ceased taking her medication on at least one occasion as she disliked the way it made her feel. The police officers were familiar with this scenario. It wasn't uncommon for them to see erratic behavior from individuals with untreated mental
由于凯莉现在知道她住在哪里，利兹向奥马哈警察局报了案。警察无法追踪到凯莉，因为她辞去了工作，在堪萨斯州担任新职务，但对她背景的一些挖掘显示，她几年前被诊断出患有双相情感障碍。据凯莉的母亲说，她之前至少有一次停止服用药物，因为她不喜欢药物让她产生的感觉。警察对这种情况很熟悉。他们看到患有未治疗精神疾病或障碍的个人出现不稳定行为并不罕见。
illness or disorders. They suspected that Carrie was experiencing some kind of mental health crisis and was stalking her ex as a result. Until they could find her and question her about it, there was little they could do to stop it. Meanwhile, Dave Krupper continued to be tormented by Carrie. By the end of 2012, he was receiving up to 60 emails and text messages from her a day. It didn't matter if Dave changed his phone number, she always managed to find him again.
他们怀疑凯莉正在经历某种心理健康危机，并因此跟踪她的前任。在他们找到她并就此事询问她之前，他们几乎无法阻止它。与此同时，戴夫·克鲁帕继续受到凯莉的折磨。到 2012 年底，他每天收到多达 60 封来自她的电子邮件和短信。戴夫是否更换电话号码并不重要，她总是能再次找到他。
He also tried blocking Carrie's number, but this didn't stop the abuse either. More messages simply came through from new untraceable numbers. Dave saved each one so he could keep track of them all, naming every phone number after Carrie. Eventually, he had 18 different carries saved in his phone. Carrie also used a wide variety of email addresses to harass Dave. Some of them featured handles that incorporated Dave's name, such as Krupper Carrie 76 and Dave's girl Carrie.
他也试图屏蔽凯莉的号码，但这也没有阻止虐待。更多信息只是从新的无法追踪的号码发来。戴夫保存了每一条信息，以便他能跟踪所有信息，并以凯莉的名字命名每个电话号码。最终，他的手机里保存了 18 个不同的“凯莉”。凯莉还使用各种各样的电子邮件地址来骚扰戴夫。其中一些使用了包含戴夫名字的句柄，例如“Krupper Carrie 76”和“Dave's girl Carrie”。
Carrie made lots of threats and outrageous claims. She insisted that she was pregnant with Dave's child and that she'd moved into his apartment complex. One evening, Dave was watching television at home when his phone dinged with a notification. He glanced down to see a message from Carrie, I see you in the chair with your feet propped up, you're wearing your blue t-shirt. Dave was horrified. Carrie had described his posture and outfit accurately.
凯莉发出了许多威胁和离谱的声明。她坚持说她怀了戴夫的孩子，并且她已经搬进了他的公寓大楼。一天晚上，戴夫正在家里看电视，手机响起了通知。他低头一看，看到了凯莉发来的一条信息：“我看到你坐在椅子上，脚翘着，你穿着蓝色 T 恤。”戴夫感到恐惧。凯莉准确地描述了他的姿势和装束。
She must have been lurking outside his window. He dashed outside to look for her. His apartment was in a large complex of a dozen brick buildings each three stories high. Grassy lawns and large leafy trees were dotted between the buildings which lent the space a woodland feel. There were plenty of spots where someone could lurk unseen. Dave peered through the dark but saw no sign of Carrie. From then on, he started to close his blinds at night.
她一定潜伏在他的窗外。他冲到外面去寻找她。他的公寓位于一个由十几栋砖砌建筑组成的大型综合体中，每栋楼三层高。建筑之间点缀着草坪和高大的绿树，赋予了空间一种林地的感觉。有很多地方可以让某人潜伏而不被发现。戴夫透过黑暗凝视，但没有看到凯莉的踪迹。从那时起，他开始在晚上拉上百叶窗。
His incidents didn't just occur when Dave was alone. He and his ex Liz began to seek solace in one another as the stalking escalated and their rekindled romance only seemed to spur Carrie on. Sometimes the pair would be at Dave's apartment chatting on the couch or watching a movie when their cell phones would ring out with simultaneous notifications. They checked their respective devices and see Carrie had messaged them both at the same time, telling Liz she was a whore while insisting she would never leave Dave alone. The tormented couple ventured their frustrations to one another and even coined a nickname
他的事件不仅仅发生在戴夫独处时。随着跟踪升级，他和前任利兹开始在彼此身上寻求慰藉，他们重燃的恋情似乎只会刺激凯莉。有时两人会在戴夫的公寓里在沙发上聊天或看电影，这时他们的手机会同时响起通知。他们检查各自的设备，看到凯莉同时给他们两人发了信息，告诉利兹她是个婊子，同时坚持她永远不会放过戴夫。这对受折磨的情侣向对方倾诉了他们的挫折，甚至给他们的跟踪者起了一个绰号：
for their stalker, Crazy Carrie. At 12.30 am on Sunday, January 6, 2013, Dave Krupa received a disturbing email from Carrie Farver. It contained an attachment. A photograph of a woman with dark hair called up in the boot of a car with her hands bound and duct tape over her mouth. Her face was turned slightly away, making it difficult to see her features. The accompanying message warned, You will do exactly as I say, and then I will let her
“疯狂凯莉”。2013 年 1 月 6 日星期日凌晨 12 点 30 分，戴夫·克鲁帕收到了一封来自凯莉·法弗（Carrie Farver）的令人不安的电子邮件。它包含一个附件。一张照片，照片中一名黑发女子蜷缩在汽车后备箱里，双手被绑，嘴上贴着胶带。她的脸稍微转开，很难看清她的特征。随附的信息警告说：“你会完全按照我说的做，然后我会放她
go. Carrie told Dave that she'd abducted Liz and was holding her hostage. Dave was to call Liz's phone and dump her via voicemail. Liz would then play the message out loud to Carrie to confirm it had been received. Then Dave had to get back together with Carrie. If this was done, Carrie would let Liz go. If you don't agree, she will stay in my trunk, the message concluded. This was a serious escalation in behaviour, but Dave wasn't sure if the threat was genuine.
走。”凯莉告诉戴夫，她绑架了利兹，并把她扣为人质。戴夫必须拨打利兹的电话，并通过语音信箱与她分手。利兹随后会大声播放这条信息给凯莉听，以确认它已被收到。然后戴夫必须和凯莉复合。如果这样做，凯莉就会放走利兹。信息总结道：“如果你不同意，她就会留在我的后备箱里。”这是行为上的严重升级，但戴夫不确定威胁是否真实。
The photograph of the woman almost looked like a stock image. He texted Liz right away, but there was no reply. Dave tried not to get nervous. It was late at night, so Liz was most likely sleeping. He heard back from Liz the next morning. Relieved that she was okay and the whole thing had been nothing more than a sick joke, Dave replied to her. Psycho was playing games.
照片中的女人看起来几乎像是一张库存图片。他立刻给利兹发了短信，但没有回复。戴夫尽量不紧张。已经是深夜了，所以利兹很可能在睡觉。第二天早上他收到了利兹的回信。戴夫松了一口气，知道她没事，整件事只不过是一个恶心的玩笑，他回复了她。“疯子在玩游戏。”
Several days later on January 10, Dave was driving home from work when he saw a familiar vehicle parked outside one of the buildings in his apartment complex. It was a black Ford Explorer covered in snow from a recent storm. Dave immediately recognised it as Carrie's car, the same one that he'd worked on when she'd brought it into the auto repair shop two months earlier. She phoned the police to report the vehicle, and it was towed to the Omaha Police Department and impounded. Dave showed an officer the message from Carrie that said she had moved into the same complex
几天后的 1 月 10 日，戴夫下班开车回家时，看到一辆熟悉的车辆停在他公寓大楼的一栋楼外。那是一辆黑色福特探险者，上面覆盖着最近一场风暴带来的积雪。戴夫立刻认出那是凯莉的车，就是两个月前她把它开到汽车修理店时他修理的那辆。她打电话给警察报告了这辆车，它被拖到了奥马哈警察局并被扣押。戴夫向一名警官展示了凯莉发来的信息，说她已经搬进了和他同一个综合体
as him, but the address she provided didn't correlate to any of the apartments. It seemed to be a fake number. Police dismissed her claim as another empty threat, but asked if they could download the contents of Dave's and Liz's phones to aid in the investigation of their stalker. Both were happy to oblige. Throughout the first half of 2013, Carrie Farver continued to make life a living hell for Dave Krupper. One evening he was out visiting his children at their mother's home when he received an
，但她提供的地址与任何公寓都不对应。这似乎是一个假号码。警察驳回了她的说法，认为是另一个空洞的威胁，但询问他们是否可以下载戴夫和利兹手机的内容，以协助调查他们的跟踪者。两人都很乐意配合。2013 年上半年，凯莉·法弗继续让戴夫·克鲁帕的生活变成人间地狱。一天晚上，他出去看望他母亲家的孩子们时，收到了一封
email that read, I told you I was coming to see you tonight. You weren't there. I took out a window. When Dave returned home, he saw that a brick had been thrown through one of his bedroom windows. Another time, he went outside to find his car scratched with the words, Dave loves fat horse.
电子邮件，上面写着：“我告诉过你我今晚要来看你。你不在那里。我打破了一扇窗户。”当戴夫回到家时，他看到一块砖头被扔进了他的一间卧室窗户。还有一次，他走到外面发现他的车被划伤了，上面写着：“戴夫爱肥马。”
Carrie also maintained her harassment of Liz Golia, Dave's ex Sammy Flora, and any other women who Dave took an interest in. As well as threatening the women themselves, she would make threats against any children they had and sometimes send disturbing images that indicated she'd been lurking outside their homes. Occasionally, she took out her anger on the women's property. Liz Golia's car was keyed with the demand. Oh, stop seeing Dave.
凯莉还继续骚扰利兹·戈利亚、戴夫的前任艾米·弗洛拉以及戴夫感兴趣的任何其他女性。除了威胁这些女性本身，她还会威胁她们拥有的任何孩子，有时还会发送令人不安的图像，表明她一直潜伏在她们家外面。偶尔，她会把愤怒发泄在这些女性的财产上。利兹·戈利亚的车被划上了要求：“哦，别再见戴夫了。”
Carrie hadn't physically harmed anyone yet, but she constantly threatened to. In the summer of 2013, she sent Dave a particularly menacing email about Liz. I'll kill her. She stole my heart. She broke my dreams. She stole my future when she took you away from me. That whore will die. At 8.14am on Saturday, August 17, a call came through to the Omaha Fire Department about
凯莉还没有在身体上伤害任何人，但她不断威胁要这样做。2013 年夏天，她给戴夫发了一封关于利兹的特别威胁性的电子邮件。“我会杀了她。她偷走了我的心。她打破了我的梦想。当她把你从我身边带走时，她偷走了我的未来。那个婊子会死。”8 月 17 日星期六上午 8 点 14 分，奥马哈消防局接到一个电话，关于
a possible house fire nearby. After racing to the scene, firefighters found the remnants of a devastating blaze that had severely damaged the small split-level house. The property was home to Liz Golia and her two children. Although the fire had been extinguished, thick smoke still hung in the air, black soot covered the surfaces and the home's contents were badly charred. Even worse, several deceased bodies were found throughout, but they weren't human. Sadly, the family's four pets, two dogs, a cat and a snake, had all perished from smoke
附近可能发生的房屋火灾。在冲向现场后，消防员发现了毁灭性大火的残骸，大火严重损坏了那座小型错层式住宅。该房产是利兹·戈利亚和她的两个孩子的家。虽然火势已被扑灭，但浓烟仍悬浮在空气中，黑色烟灰覆盖了表面，房屋内的物品被严重烧焦。更糟糕的是，到处都发现了多具尸体，但它们不是人类。可悲的是，这家人养的四只宠物，两只狗、一只猫和一条蛇，都因吸入烟雾而死亡。
inhalation. Liz and her children had survived through a lucky twist of fate. They were in the process of moving and had been staying at their new home when the blaze struck. When Liz had arrived at the house earlier that morning to collect some things, she opened the front door and smoke billowed out. She had immediately called 911. As the firefighters examined the house, a couple of things caught their attention.
利兹和她的孩子们在命运的幸运转折下幸存了下来。他们正在搬家过程中，火灾发生时他们一直住在新家。当利兹那天早上早些时候到达房子收集一些东西时，她打开前门，烟雾滚滚而出。她立即拨打了 911。当消防员检查房子时，有几件事引起了他们的注意。
A gas can sat on the living room floor and a bottle of lighter fluid was found on a kitchen bench. There also appeared to be multiple points of origin. The only reason the flames hadn't engulfed the entire house was because all of its windows were shut, which prevented oxygen from sustaining the flames. Liz identified the gas can and the lighter fluid as belonging to her, but they had been moved from their usual spots in the backyard. She had also made a disturbing discovery.
客厅地板上放着一个汽油罐，厨房长凳上发现了一瓶打火机油。似乎还有多个起火点。火焰没有吞噬整个房子的唯一原因是所有的窗户都关着，这阻止了氧气维持火焰。利兹确认汽油罐和打火机油是她的，但它们已经从后院通常存放的地方被移走了。她还发现了一个令人不安的发现。
At 12.56am that morning, well before the fire was discovered, she had received an email from Carrie Farver. Nasty whore. Dave doesn't want you talking to him anymore. He wants to be with me. We are trying a new relationship. We have had sex recently. He loves me and always will.
那天凌晨 12 点 56 分，在火灾被发现之前，她收到了凯莉·法弗的一封电子邮件。“下贱的婊子。戴夫不想让你再和他说话了。他想和我在一起。我们正在尝试一段新的关系。我们最近发生了性关系。他爱我，永远都会。”
He doesn't want you back you nasty fat whore Liz. Hope you and your kids burn to death. Dave had received a similar email gloating over the fire and the presumed death of Liz and her children. He felt terrible that Liz had lost her pets and many of her belongings because of him. She refused to give Dave her new address in case Carrie found it, and Dave completely understood her fear. Carrie's behavior was escalating and she'd proved that she had no qualms about killing.
“他不想让你回来，你这个下贱的肥婊子利兹。希望你和你的孩子被烧死。”戴夫收到了一封类似的电子邮件，对火灾以及利兹和她的孩子们被推定死亡表示幸灾乐祸。他因为自己而让利兹失去了宠物和许多财物，感到非常难过。她拒绝给戴夫她的新地址，以防凯莉找到它，戴夫完全理解她的恐惧。凯莉的行为正在升级，她已经证明她毫不介意杀人。
Although Dave kept waiting for her to move on and to leave him alone, weeks turned into months and then years, but the torment continued. Finally, Dave decided to take extra measures to protect himself. His father gave him a 9mm Smith & Wesson pistol and Dave kept it in a box on a closet shelf, far enough out of reach so his children wouldn't find it, but easily accessible for him. Although Carrie continued to send him abusive texts and emails daily, she showed no further signs of acting on any of her threats. Nevertheless, the stalking was taking a toll on Dave both mentally and physically.
虽然戴夫一直等着她继续前进并让他一个人呆着，但几周变成了几个月，然后是几年，但折磨仍在继续。最后，戴夫决定采取额外措施来保护自己。他的父亲给了他一把 9 毫米史密斯威森手枪，戴夫把它放在壁橱架子上的盒子里，放在孩子们够不到的地方，但他自己很容易拿到。虽然凯莉继续每天给他发辱骂性的短信和电子邮件，但她没有表现出任何进一步采取行动威胁的迹象。尽管如此，跟踪在精神和身体上都对戴夫造成了伤害。
He began drinking at his local bar every night and eventually gained 30 pounds. His work suffered from the constant interruptions and Carrie even once vandalized the auto repair shop, spray painting the words, Dave beats women on its front windows. One night in 2014, Dave had a female friend staying with him when someone tried to break into his apartment by jiggling the front door handle. Then a brick was thrown through his bedroom window. Dave became increasingly worried about the safety of those close to him, particularly his two children.
他开始每晚在当地酒吧喝酒，最终体重增加了 30 磅。他的工作因不断的打断而受到影响，凯莉甚至有一次破坏了汽车修理店，在它的前窗上喷漆写着：“戴夫殴打女性”。2014 年的一天晚上，戴夫有一位女性朋友和他住在一起，这时有人试图通过摇晃前门把手闯入他的公寓。然后一块砖头被扔进了他的卧室窗户。戴夫越来越担心他身边人的安全，特别是他的两个孩子。
In February 2015, Dave moved from his apartment in Omaha to a new home across the border in Council Bluffs, Iowa. He hoped that the change of address would prevent Carrie from stalking him in person, but the incidents continued. After more than two years, it seemed like the harassment would never stop. One afternoon in late November 2015, Dave returned home after a day out and went into his bedroom to get something from his closet. He immediately noticed that the box he kept his gun in was sticking out over the ledge
2015 年 2 月，戴夫从奥马哈的公寓搬到了爱荷华州康瑟尔布拉夫斯边界对面的新家。他希望更换地址能阻止凯莉亲自跟踪他，但事件仍在继续。两年多后，骚扰似乎永远不会停止。2015 年 11 月下旬的一个下午，戴夫外出一天后回到家，走进卧室从壁橱里拿东西。他立即注意到他放枪的盒子正从架子的边缘突出来。
of the shelf. Dave normally kept it pushed back to ensure it was out of reach. He snatched the box and quickly opened it up. The gun was missing. A week later on Saturday, December 5, Liz Gollia decided to go for an evening stroll in Big Lake Park, a sprawling 190-acre park right near the Nebraska-Iowa border. Even though it was only around 6.30pm, it was already dark, but Liz felt safe as she wound her way along one of the walking paths.
戴夫通常把它推回去以确保它够不到。他抓起盒子，迅速打开它。枪不见了。一周后的 12 月 5 日星期六，利兹·戈利亚决定去大湖公园（Big Lake Park）散步，这是一个位于内布拉斯加州和爱荷华州边界附近、占地 190 英亩的广阔公园。尽管当时只有下午 6 点 30 分左右，天已经黑了，但利兹在沿着其中一条步行道蜿蜒前行时感到很安全。
Spotting a bench up ahead, she decided to sit and rest for a minute. She hadn't stopped for long when she saw the silhouette of a person cast over her and heard a woman's voice tell her to get down on the ground. Liz did as she was told. As she lay face down on the cold ground, the woman asked, So, you like fucking Dave? A couple of loud bangs rang out, then Liz felt a burning sensation in her left thigh. She had been shot.
看到前面有一张长椅，她决定坐下来休息一分钟。她还没停多久，就看到一个人的轮廓投射在她身上，并听到一个女人的声音告诉她趴在地上。利兹照做了。当她脸朝下躺在冰冷的地面上时，那个女人问：“所以，你喜欢和戴夫做爱？”几声巨响响起，然后利兹感到左大腿有一种灼烧感。她中枪了。
Liz managed to scramble to her feet and ran away as fast as her injury permitted. She stumbled back to her car where she'd left her cell phone and dialed 911. Sounding scared and distraught, she told the operator, I've been shot in the leg. My pant leg is soaked with blood. An officer from the Council Bluffs Police Department was dispatched to the scene and found Liz sitting on the ground next to her car, still on the phone to 911. Her leg was bleeding and she was obviously in pain.
利兹挣扎着站起来，在伤势允许的情况下尽可能快地跑开了。她跌跌撞撞地回到她留下手机的车旁，拨打了 911。她听起来很害怕和心烦意乱，告诉接线员：“我的腿中枪了。我的裤腿被血浸透了。”康瑟尔布拉夫斯警察局的一名警官被派往现场，发现利兹坐在她车旁的地上，还在和 911 通话。她的腿在流血，显然很痛苦。
Liz began telling the officer what had happened to her and revealed that she knew who had shot her. But, the shooter hadn't been Carrie Farver. It was Amy Flora. Amy Flora shot me. Three years earlier on Tuesday, November 13, 2012, Nancy Rainey had received a strange text message from her 37-year-old daughter, Carrie Farver. Carrie was staying in Omaha for the week with her new boyfriend Dave while she completed
利兹开始告诉警官她身上发生了什么，并透露她知道是谁开枪打伤了她。但是，开枪的人不是凯莉·法弗。是艾米·弗洛拉。艾米·弗洛拉开枪打了我。三年前的 2012 年 11 月 13 日星期二，南希·雷尼（Nancy Rainey）收到了她 37 岁的女儿凯莉·法弗发来的一条奇怪的短信。凯莉在奥马哈和她的新男友戴夫住了一周，同时她完成了
a big work project. Therefore, Nancy was looking after Carrie's 14-year-old son, Max. Nancy was expecting Carrie back in a few days, but Carrie's text said she'd been offered a new job in Kansas and planned to take it. Nancy was baffled. She was very close to her daughter and they spoke on the phone daily. As far as Nancy was aware, Carrie loved her job. It seemed odd that she'd abruptly quit.
一个大型工作项目。因此，南希一直在照顾凯莉 14 岁的儿子马克斯（Max）。南希预计凯莉几天后回来，但凯莉的短信说她得到了一份堪萨斯州的新工作，并计划接受它。南希感到困惑。她和女儿关系非常亲密，他们每天都在电话里交谈。据南希所知，凯莉热爱她的工作。她突然辞职似乎很奇怪。
Carrie also owned her own house in her hometown of Macedonia, so an interstate move made no sense from that perspective either. Nancy asked Max if he knew anything about a job in Kansas. He said his mother had previously mentioned looking at a position there, which made Nancy feel somewhat reassured, but she was still unsettled. The tone of Carrie's messages seemed wrong and it didn't make sense that she wouldn't call Nancy to chat like she usually did. Carrie's half-brother was due to get married in several days' time.
凯莉还在她的家乡马其顿拥有自己的房子，所以从这个角度来看，跨州搬家也没有意义。南希问马克斯是否知道关于堪萨斯州工作的任何事情。他说他母亲之前提到过在那里看一个职位，这让南希感到有些放心，但她仍然感到不安。凯莉信息的语气似乎不对，而且她不像平时那样打电话给南希聊天也说不通。凯莉同父异母的兄弟几天后就要结婚了。
Nancy figured she would see her daughter then and figure out what was going on. But the wedding came and went with no sign of Carrie. Despite that something was seriously wrong, Nancy decided to call the police. The officer who spoke with her didn't seem overly concerned. Carrie was a grown woman and was entitled to take some time to herself if she wanted to. Besides, she was still in contact via text messages and social media. On November 21, she announced on her Facebook page, moving to Kansas for a great job, will
南希想她那时会见到她的女儿，并弄清楚发生了什么。但婚礼来了又去，没有凯莉的踪影。尽管事情严重不对劲，南希还是决定报警。和她交谈的警官似乎并不太担心。凯莉是一个成年女性，如果她愿意，有权花点时间独处。此外，她仍然通过短信和社交媒体保持联系。11 月 21 日，她在她的 Facebook 页面上宣布：“搬到堪萨斯州从事一份很棒的工作，会
miss family and great friends. Nancy mentioned that Carrie had always been a happy, vivacious and fun-loving person, but she'd experienced a difficult period roughly a decade earlier and was eventually diagnosed as having bipolar disorder. The officers latched on to Carrie's bipolar diagnosis as a likely explanation for her sudden erratic behavior and wondered if she'd stop taking her medication. They'd seen similar things happen before. The officers processed the report and Carrie was officially listed as a missing person,
想念家人和伟大的朋友。”南希提到凯莉一直是一个快乐、活泼和热爱生活的人，但她在大约十年前经历了一段困难时期，最终被诊断出患有双相情感障碍。警官们抓住了凯莉的双相情感障碍诊断，作为她突然不稳定行为的可能解释，并想知道她是否停止了服药。他们以前见过类似的事情发生。警官们处理了报告，凯莉被正式列为失踪人员，
but the case wasn't a priority. A couple of weeks after Carrie vanished, Nancy received a message from her daughter saying that her Black Ford Explorer was missing. The vehicle was registered in Nancy's name, so she reported it stolen. About a month later, the Explorer was discovered by Dave Krupa in the parking lot of his apartment complex. After towing the car, police searched inside and found it was clean except for a stain from a spilled drink on one of the seats.
但该案件不是优先事项。在凯莉失踪几周后，南希收到女儿的一条信息，说她的黑色福特探险者不见了。这辆车是以南希的名义注册的，所以她报告它被盗了。大约一个月后，戴夫·克鲁帕在他的公寓大楼停车场发现了这辆探险者。在拖走汽车后，警察进行了搜查，发现除了其中一个座位上有溢出的饮料污渍外，车内很干净。
There were few personal belongings inside and no driver's manual or registration in the glove compartment. Tucked into one of the drink holders was an empty mint container. Once the vehicle was processed, it was returned to Nancy. Those close to Carrie were growing increasingly concerned. As well as missing her brother's wedding, she hadn't shown up at any of her son's sporting events. This was completely out of character as she always made sure to support Max in his extracurricular
里面几乎没有个人物品，手套箱里也没有驾驶手册或登记证。其中一个饮料架里塞着一个空的薄荷糖盒。车辆处理完毕后，它被归还给了南希。那些与凯莉亲近的人越来越担心。除了错过她兄弟的婚礼外，她也没有出现在她儿子的任何体育赛事中。这完全不符合她的性格，因为她总是确保支持马克斯的课外
activities. Carrie's father, Denny, had also been sick with cancer for a long time and she regularly visited him in hospital. However, the visit stopped and when Denny died a month after Carrie disappeared, she didn't show up for his funeral. Yet, the text messages kept coming. Carrie had always been meticulous with her spelling and grammar, but now she was sending garbled texts riddled with spelling, punctuation, and grammar mistakes.
活动。凯莉的父亲丹尼（Denny）也长期患有癌症，她经常去医院看望他。然而，探视停止了，当丹尼在凯莉失踪一个月后去世时，她没有出现在他的葬礼上。然而，短信不断发来。凯莉在拼写和语法方面一直很细致，但现在她发送的短信乱七八糟，充满了拼写、标点和语法错误。
Shortly after Carrie vanished, she messaged Nancy explaining that she'd sold her bedroom furniture online. She asked if Nancy could let the buyer into her house to collect it. As proof of the purchase, Carrie sent a photo of a cheque made out to her for $5,000. Nancy was dubious. Carrie's bedroom dresser was an antique that had belonged to her great-grandmother. It seemed impossible that Carrie would want to part with it. Nancy tapped out a reply.
在凯莉失踪后不久，她给南希发信息解释说她在网上卖掉了她的卧室家具。她问南希是否可以让买家进入她的房子去取。作为购买证明，凯莉发送了一张开给她的 5,000 美元支票的照片。南希表示怀疑。凯莉的卧室梳妆台是一件属于她曾祖母的古董。凯莉想和它分开似乎是不可能的。南希敲出一条回复。
I need to hear your voice first so I know it's really you. An aggressive response from Carrie's number soon came through, accusing Nancy of being controlling and a bad mother. A couple of months later, Nancy was scrolling through Facebook when she came across a new profile under the name Carrie Father. The profile picture was a photograph of Carrie with her late father. Examining the profile, Nancy saw a post that mentioned Dave Krupa, the man Carrie had been dating at the time of her disappearance.
“我需要先听到你的声音，这样我才知道真的是你。”凯莉的号码很快发来了一条攻击性的回复，指责南希控制欲强，是个坏母亲。几个月后，南希在浏览 Facebook 时，偶然发现了一个名为“Carrie Father”的新个人资料。个人资料图片是凯莉和她已故父亲的照片。检查个人资料时，南希看到了一篇提到戴夫·克鲁帕的帖子，他是凯莉失踪时正在约会的男人。
Nancy sometimes wondered if Dave was responsible for whatever had happened to Carrie, but she had no way of contacting him. According to the police handling Carrie's missing persons file, Dave was the one being harassed by her. The Facebook post said that Dave and Carrie had recently gotten engaged and showed a photograph of a stubby hand wearing a diamond ring. It looked nothing like Carrie's hand, which had very long fingers. Nancy was now certain that somebody else was actively pretending to be her daughter.
南希有时想知道戴夫是否对凯莉身上发生的事情负责，但她无法联系到他。据处理凯莉失踪人员档案的警察说，戴夫是被她骚扰的人。Facebook 帖子说戴夫和凯莉最近订婚了，并展示了一张戴着钻戒的粗短手的照片。它看起来一点也不像凯莉的手，她的手指非常长。南希现在确信有其他人正在积极假装是她的女儿。
Carrie's son agreed. Like Nancy, he couldn't believe Carrie would ever abandon him, let alone take off without any proper explanation. One day, Max received a message from the new Facebook account using his mother's name. He opened it and read the words, Hey little man, how are you? His mother had never called him little man before, and Max was unsettled by the message. He didn't reply, but then a couple of weeks later, he had an idea. He went onto Facebook and typed a response.
凯莉的儿子也同意。像南希一样，他无法相信凯莉会抛弃他，更不用说在没有任何适当解释的情况下离开了。一天，马克斯收到了使用他母亲名字的新 Facebook 账户发来的一条信息。他打开它，读到了这些话：“嘿，小家伙，你好吗？”他母亲以前从未叫过他“小家伙”，马克斯对这条信息感到不安。他没有回复，但几周后，他想到了一个主意。他上了 Facebook 并输入了回复。
What was the name of our first boxer? Who was my best friend when I was growing up? These were questions only his mother could answer. Max waited and waited, but a reply never arrived. Carrie's family was certain she had fallen victim to foul play, but had no way of proving it, and investigators seemed unwilling to listen. One night, her mother Nancy had an incredibly vivid dream in which Carrie's father, Denny, appeared before her.
“我们第一只拳师犬的名字是什么？我长大时最好的朋友是谁？”这些是只有他母亲才能回答的问题。马克斯等啊等，但回复从未到来。凯莉的家人确信她成了谋杀案的受害者，但无法证明这一点，调查人员似乎不愿意倾听。一天晚上，她的母亲南希做了一个极其生动的梦，梦中凯莉的父亲丹尼出现在她面前。
As he looked into Nancy's eyes, he said in a soft voice, Nancy, she's with me. The dream felt so real that Nancy immediately woke up. She was comforted by the thought that Carrie was safe in the care of her beloved father, while also struck with grief at the certain knowledge that her daughter was dead. When Liz Golia was shot in Big Lake Park in December of 2015, more than three years had passed since Nancy first reported Carrie is missing. During those three years, Liz had received thousands of abusive emails and text messages from someone using Carrie's identity.
当他看着南希的眼睛时，他轻声说：“南希，她和我在一起。”这个梦感觉如此真实，以至于南希立刻醒了过来。她被凯莉在她深爱的父亲照顾下是安全的想法所安慰，同时也因为确信女儿已经死了而感到悲痛。当利兹·戈利亚于 2015 年 12 月在大湖公园中枪时，距离南希第一次报告凯莉失踪已经过去了三年多。在这三年里，利兹收到了数千封来自使用凯莉身份的人的辱骂性电子邮件和短信。
The home had been vandalized, then burnt down with her four pets inside, and now she had been shot in the leg while out on a walk. As she told the police, it didn't make sense that Carrie would develop such an obsession with her, given that Carrie had only dated Dave Krupa for two weeks. Liz had theorized that Dave's ex, Amy Flora, had been behind the harassment all along. Amy had recently started sending Liz some nasty messages via Facebook, prompting Liz to wonder if Amy had been framing Carrie for stalking. As the mother of Dave's two children, Amy had far more reason to be possessive of him
房子被破坏，然后被烧毁，她的四只宠物在里面，现在她在散步时腿部中枪。正如她告诉警察的那样，考虑到凯莉只和戴夫·克鲁帕约会了两周，凯莉会对她产生如此强烈的痴迷是没有道理的。利兹推测戴夫的前任艾米·弗洛拉一直在这场骚扰的背后。艾米最近开始通过 Facebook 给利兹发一些恶毒的信息，促使利兹怀疑艾米是否一直在陷害凯莉进行跟踪。作为戴夫两个孩子的母亲，艾米有更多的理由对他产生占有欲
than Carrie did. Liz and Dave were no longer seeing each other at this point, but that didn't seem to matter to Amy. Liz also knew that Amy had a spare key to Dave's apartment, and his gun had recently disappeared from there. Detectives were intrigued by Liz's theory. They hadn't been able to track down Liz's shooter despite dispatching a helicopter team and search party to scour the park.
而不是凯莉。利兹和戴夫此时不再见面了，但这似乎对艾米来说并不重要。利兹还知道艾米有戴夫公寓的备用钥匙，而他的枪最近从那里消失了。侦探们对利兹的理论很感兴趣。尽管派遣了直升机小组和搜查队去搜查公园，但他们一直无法追踪到利兹的枪手。
However, they had recently found some unidentified human remains, and were starting to wonder if perhaps they belonged to Carrie Farver. As detailed by author Leslie Ruhl in her book A Tangled Web, one of the detectives told Liz, I'm thinking if Amy was bold enough to go and shoot you, she could have easily been bold enough to have done something to Carrie. They asked Liz to forward on any further messages Amy sent her, and downloaded the contents of her phone so they could examine everything she'd already received for themselves.
然而，他们最近发现了一些身份不明的人类遗骸，并开始怀疑它们是否属于凯莉·法弗。正如作者莱斯利·鲁尔（Leslie Ruhl）在她的书《纠缠的网》（A Tangled Web）中所述，其中一名侦探告诉利兹：“我在想，如果艾米有胆量去开枪打你，她完全有胆量对凯莉做些什么。”他们要求利兹转发艾米发给她的任何进一步信息，并下载了她手机的内容，以便他们可以亲自检查她已经收到的所有信息。
On December 20, five days after Liz Gollia was shot, an email landed in her inbox which she immediately forwarded to investigators. Detective Jim Doty, who worked for the Pottawatomie County Sheriff's Office in Iowa, scanned his eyes over the long message which had been sent to Liz from Amy Flora. It read in part, When I met crazy Carrie, she would not stop talking about Dave and him being her husband. She tried to attack me, but I attacked her with a knife. I stabbed her three to four times in the stomach area.
12 月 20 日，在利兹·戈利亚中枪五天后，一封电子邮件进入了她的收件箱，她立即将其转发给了调查人员。在爱荷华州波塔瓦托米县治安官办公室工作的吉姆·多蒂（Jim Doty）侦探扫视了这条发给利兹的长信息，该信息来自艾米·弗洛拉。它部分写道：“当我遇到疯狂凯莉时，她不停地谈论戴夫，说他是她的丈夫。她试图攻击我，但我用刀攻击了她。我刺了她的腹部区域三到四次。”
I then took her out and burned her. I stuffed her body in a garbage can with crap. She was carried out to the dumpster, probably when Dave took my garbage out for me. So be glad I did not do you that way, Liz. This confession was beyond disturbing, but with no evidence and no body, it was just words on a screen. Sheriff's reassure to Liz that they were monitoring the situation and keeping a close eye on Amy Flora.
然后我把她带出去烧了。我把她的尸体和垃圾一起塞进垃圾桶里。她被运到了垃圾箱，可能是在戴夫帮我倒垃圾的时候。所以，莉兹，你应该庆幸我没有那样对你。这份供词令人极度不安，但由于没有证据，也没有尸体，这不过是屏幕上的文字而已。警长向莉兹保证，他们正在监控局势，并密切关注艾米·弗洛拉。
All they needed was some specific details that only the killer could know and they would be able to make an arrest. In subsequent messages over the following months, Amy provided slightly different versions of Carrie's father's murder, but all involved her stabbing Carrie in Carrie's car, wrapping her in a tarp, then burning and dumping her body. In one telling, Amy claimed she stabbed Carrie, then drove her out into the woods. Carrie was still alive and begged for her life, but Amy simply looked on, watching the life drain from her body.
他们只需要一些只有凶手才知道的具体细节，就能实施逮捕。在接下来的几个月里，艾米在后续的信息中提供了关于凯莉父亲谋杀案的略有不同的版本，但都涉及她用刀刺伤凯莉，将其裹在防水布中，然后焚烧并抛尸。在其中一种说法中，艾米声称她刺伤了凯莉，然后开车把她带到树林里。凯莉当时还活着，苦苦哀求饶命，但艾米只是冷眼旁观，看着生命从她体内流逝。
To prove she wasn't, quote, lying about offing that crazy bitch, Amy described a yin yang tattoo that was on Carrie's thigh, a detail that hadn't been mentioned in the media. Amy described how after killing Carrie, she had cleaned her car, driven to her home and gathered up some of Carrie's personal belongings to make it look as though she'd decided to leave of her own accord. Amy accurately described the layout and look of Carrie's house. She said she'd contacted Carrie's mother Nancy, posing as Carrie, to cover up her crime. She also parked Carrie's car at Dave Krupper's apartment complex so it would look like she
为了证明她没有“撒谎杀掉那个疯婆子”，艾米描述了凯莉大腿上的一个阴阳纹身，这是一个媒体从未提及的细节。艾米描述了她在杀死凯莉后，是如何清理她的车，开车到她家，并收集了一些凯莉的私人物品，让看起来像是她决定自愿离开一样。艾米准确地描述了凯莉家的布局和外观。她说她曾冒充凯莉联系了凯莉的母亲南希，以掩盖她的罪行。她还把凯莉的车停在戴夫·克鲁珀的公寓大楼，这样看起来就像是她
was stalking him. When the police had initially searched Carrie's father's car, they had no idea it was a possible crime scene and had only processed it as a stolen vehicle. However, the original search had uncovered one clue. The vehicle was exceptionally clean with no fingerprints anywhere, except for one recovered from an empty mint container in one of the car's cup holders. This fingerprint hadn't belonged to Carrie Farver or anyone in the police database. On February 18, 2016, detectives obtained the vehicle from its new owner and conducted
在跟踪他。当警察最初搜查凯莉父亲的车时，他们根本不知道这可能是一个犯罪现场，只是将其作为被盗车辆处理。然而，最初的搜查发现了一条线索。这辆车异常干净，没有任何指纹，除了在车内杯架的一个空薄荷糖盒上发现了一个指纹。这个指纹不属于凯莉·法弗，也不属于警方数据库中的任何人。2016年2月18日，侦探从新车主那里获得了这辆车，并进行了
a second search. Amy claimed she'd stabbed Carrie while she was seated in her car, so the detectives removed the fabric upholstery from the driver's seat and sprayed it with luminol, looking for any sign of blood. There was nothing there. On the front passenger seat was a faint red stain. During the original search, this had been determined to be the result of a spilled drink. Tearing off the seat cover to expose the foam beneath, the detectives realized the red stain
第二次搜查。艾米声称她在凯莉坐在车里时刺伤了她，所以侦探们拆下了驾驶座的织物内饰，并喷洒了鲁米诺试剂，寻找任何血迹。那里什么也没有。前排乘客座椅上有一个淡淡的红色污渍。在最初的搜查中，这被确定为洒出的饮料造成的。撕开座套露出下面的泡沫后，侦探们意识到这个红色污渍
was roughly the size of an adult hand with several smaller spots surrounding it. This time, the luminol reacted. DNA testing confirmed that the blood belonged to Carrie Farver. A week later, on February 25, 2016, detectives were ready to make an arrest. In spring of 2015, detectives Jim Doty and Ryan Avis overheard some chat around the Potta Whatamie County Sheriff's Department about a woman named Carrie Farver who had gone missing. Intrigued by what they heard, they requested the case be reassigned to them. So far, Carrie's disappearance had been treated as an adult leaving of her own accord.
大约有一个成年人的手掌大小，周围还有几个较小的斑点。这一次，鲁米诺试剂产生了反应。DNA检测证实血迹属于凯莉·法弗。一周后，即2016年2月25日，侦探们准备实施逮捕。2015年春天，侦探吉姆·多蒂和瑞安·阿维斯在波塔瓦塔米县警长办公室听到了一些关于一名叫凯莉·法弗的女子失踪的闲聊。他们对所听到的内容很感兴趣，于是要求将此案重新分配给他们。到目前为止，凯莉的失踪一直被视为成年人自愿离家出走。
When a sheriff's deputy tried to track Carrie down after her mother first reported her missing, he received a number of text messages from Carrie's phone, including one that read, I don't care about this missing person report, but I would really appreciate it if you leave Dave Krupa out of it. I will be leaving the state. My mother overreacted. I have been to my house a few times. In the two and a half years that followed, Carrie remained elusive, but her harassment of Dave Krupa continued. Multiple Facebook accounts under her name featured a long rant about Dave,
当一名警长副手在凯莉的母亲首次报告她失踪后试图追踪凯莉时，他收到了来自凯莉手机的几条短信，其中一条写道：“我不关心这份失踪人口报告，但我真的希望你不要把戴夫·克鲁珀牵扯进来。我将离开这个州。我母亲反应过度了。我去过我家几次。”在随后的两年半里，凯莉一直行踪不明，但她对戴夫·克鲁珀的骚扰仍在继续。以她名字命名的多个Facebook账户发布了关于戴夫的长篇大论，
which was totally out of character for Carrie, who had never previously made any angry social media posts. A YouTube user with the name Carrie Farver posted a video titled, My Husband's Cheating Place. It had been filmed outside of Dave's apartment complex. It seemed as though Carrie was all over the internet, even though no one had seen her in real life. When her missing persons file was handed over to detectives Doty and Avis, they decided to investigate differently. Detective Avis would look into Carrie's disappearance as though she was still alive, while Detective Doty would investigate it as though she were deceased.
这与凯莉的性格完全不符，她以前从未发布过任何愤怒的社交媒体帖子。一个名为凯莉·法弗的YouTube用户发布了一个名为《我丈夫的出轨场所》的视频。视频是在戴夫的公寓大楼外拍摄的。尽管现实生活中没有人见过她，但凯莉似乎无处不在。当她的失踪人口档案移交给多蒂和阿维斯侦探时，他们决定以不同的方式进行调查。阿维斯侦探将把凯莉的失踪当作她还活着来调查，而多蒂侦探则将把此案当作她已经死亡来调查。
By considering both possibilities, they hoped to discover the truth. It soon struck the detectives how there was no real trace of Carrie after November 13, 2012, aside from some out-of-character electronic communications. The last time her money had been touched was on November 16, 2012, three days after she was last seen. Somebody had used Carrie's debit card to make two separate purchases at two different discount stores in Omaha. Other than that, her bank accounts had been left alone. Everything seemed to suggest that Detective Doty's angle was the correct one, that Carrie Farver was deceased. In early 2013, Dave Krupa and Liz Golia had allowed their phones to be downloaded as part of the investigation into Carrie's stalking.
通过考虑这两种可能性，他们希望能发现真相。侦探们很快注意到，除了几条性格不符的电子通讯外，2012年11月13日之后，凯莉没有任何真实的踪迹。她最后一次动用资金是在2012年11月16日，即她最后一次露面三天后。有人用凯莉的借记卡在奥马哈的两家不同的折扣店进行了两次单独的购物。除此之外，她的银行账户一直无人动用。一切似乎都表明多蒂侦探的角度是正确的，即凯莉·法弗已经死亡。2013年初，戴夫·克鲁珀和莉兹·戈利亚允许警方下载他们的手机数据，作为对凯莉跟踪案调查的一部分。
Detectives Avis and Doty combed through the pages and pages of data and noticed some interesting things. On November 6 and November 7, 2012, roughly a week before Carrie went missing, Liz Golia had made six separate calls to the same landline, Carrie Farver's home phone. All of the calls were brief, with the longest lasting 33 seconds. Why had Liz been calling Carrie in early November when the two didn't even know each other? There was also a series of photographs that Liz's phone had captured on December 24, 2012, more than a month after Carrie's disappearance. They showed Carrie's Black Ford Explorer and were taken weeks before Dave Krupa reported finding it parked near his apartment.
阿维斯和多蒂侦探仔细梳理了页数众多的数据，并注意到了一些有趣的事情。2012年11月6日和11月7日，也就是凯莉失踪前一周左右，莉兹·戈利亚曾六次拨打同一个座机号码，即凯莉·法弗的家庭电话。所有的通话都很简短，最长的一次持续了33秒。为什么莉兹会在11月初给凯莉打电话，而当时两人甚至互不相识？莉兹的手机还在2012年12月24日，即凯莉失踪一个多月后，拍摄了一系列照片。照片显示了凯莉的黑色福特探险者，拍摄时间比戴夫·克鲁珀报告在公寓附近发现它停放的时间早了几周。
The police had prints on file for Liz, whose full name was Shana Elizabeth Golia. When Detective Doty compared these to the one recovered from the mint container in Carrie's car, he found it was a perfect match. Dave Krupa had met Liz Golia in the summer of 2012 via the dating website Plenty of Fish. She was one of the first women he started seeing after breaking up with his longtime partner Amy Flora. Dave was physically attracted to Liz but didn't feel a strong connection to her. Their conversations were never particularly deep and Liz took no interest in reading or current events like Dave did. They dated casually, with Dave making it clear that he wasn't interested in a committed relationship.
警方有莉兹的指纹记录，她的全名是莎娜·伊丽莎白·戈利亚。当多蒂侦探将这些指纹与凯莉车内薄荷糖盒上提取的指纹进行比对时，他发现完全吻合。戴夫·克鲁珀是在2012年夏天通过约会网站“Plenty of Fish”认识莉兹·戈利亚的。她是他在与长期伴侣艾米·弗洛拉分手后开始交往的第一批女性之一。戴夫被莉兹的身体所吸引，但并没有感觉到与她有强烈的联系。他们的谈话从来都不深入，莉兹也不像戴夫那样对阅读或时事感兴趣。他们随意约会，戴夫明确表示他对一段承诺关系不感兴趣。
At the same time, he kept seeing other women. Liz frequently pressured Dave for something more exclusive but he wouldn't change his mind. A few months later in October, when Dave met Carrie's father at his work, their connection was instant. As well as finding Carrie extremely pretty, Dave was blown away by how incredibly intelligent, kind and fun she was. The attraction was mutual, with Carrie later telling a friend that although Dave wasn't her usual type, she was inexplicably drawn to him. At their first date, the conversation flowed and Carrie laughed more than she had in a long time. When Dave invited her back to his place, she took him up on the offer.
与此同时，他还在和其他女性交往。莉兹经常向戴夫施压，要求一段更排他的关系，但他不为所动。几个月后的10月，当戴夫在工作时遇到凯莉的父亲时，他们瞬间产生了共鸣。戴夫不仅觉得凯莉非常漂亮，而且被她的聪明、善良和风趣所折服。这种吸引力是相互的，凯莉后来告诉一位朋友，虽然戴夫不是她通常喜欢的类型，但她莫名其妙地被他吸引了。在第一次约会时，谈话很流畅，凯莉笑得比过去很长一段时间都要多。当戴夫邀请她回他家时，她接受了邀请。
But she had to make one thing clear, she wasn't looking for anything serious and didn't want a boyfriend. Dave later reported feeling like he'd hit the jackpot at this moment. He'd found an amazing woman who wanted the exact same thing as him. There was just one problem. During Dave's first date with Carrie, his phone started blowing up with calls and messages from Liz. Dave ignored his phone for as long as possible but eventually excused himself so he could call Liz back. She said she needed to collect some things she'd left at his apartment. Dave responded that he was on a date and it wasn't a good time.
但她必须明确一点，她不想找认真的关系，也不想要男朋友。戴夫后来报告说，那一刻他感觉自己中了头奖。他找到了一个完美的女人，而且她想要的东西和他完全一样。只有一个问题。在戴夫和凯莉第一次约会时，他的手机开始不断收到莉兹的电话和信息。戴夫尽可能地忽略手机，但最终还是找借口离开去回莉兹的电话。她说她需要去拿一些留在戴夫公寓的东西。戴夫回答说他正在约会，现在不是好时机。
When Dave and Carrie got back to his place, they'd barely walked through the front door when Dave's phone started ringing again, along with his apartment security buzzer. Liz had shown up in person, determined to pick up her belongings. Dave explained the situation to Carrie who laughed it off and said she'd leave so he could sort everything out. She briefly passed Liz as she exited the apartment but gave no indication she was bothered by Liz's presence. Liz rushed into Dave's home upset and eager to speak with him. However, Dave was irritated by the interruption and asked her to leave as soon as she gathered up her possessions. Once Liz was out of the apartment, Dave called Carrie and she invited him over to her place. That was the beginning of their two week relationship.
当戴夫和凯莉回到他家时，他们刚走进前门，戴夫的手机又响了，公寓的安保门铃也响了。莉兹亲自找上门来，执意要拿回她的东西。戴夫向凯莉解释了情况，凯莉笑着说她会离开，让他处理好一切。她在离开公寓时与莉兹擦肩而过，但没有表现出被莉兹的出现所困扰。莉兹心烦意乱地冲进戴夫家，急于和他谈话。然而，戴夫对这种打扰感到恼火，并要求她在拿走财物后立即离开。莉兹离开公寓后，戴夫给凯莉打了电话，她邀请他去她家。那是他们两周关系的开始。
The last time Dave Krupa ever saw Carrie father was at around 6.30 am on Tuesday November 13, 2012. Carrie had been sitting on his couch using her laptop and Dave had kissed her goodbye before leaving for work. A few hours later at 9.54, Carrie's phone was used to log into her Facebook account and whoever did so unfriended Dave Krupa. Shortly after, Dave received a strange text from Carrie asking if they should move in together, a question completely at odds with her prior approach to their relationship. When he said no, a torrent of abuse began that would continue for years. Two days later, one of Carrie's supervisors at work received a text from her phone that read, I won't be coming back. I'm taking a job in Kansas. Sorry for the short notice.
戴夫·克鲁珀最后一次见到凯莉·法弗是在2012年11月13日星期二早上6点30分左右。凯莉当时正坐在他的沙发上用笔记本电脑，戴夫在去上班前吻别了她。几个小时后的9点54分，凯莉的手机被用来登录她的Facebook账户，登录者删除了戴夫·克鲁珀的好友。不久之后，戴夫收到凯莉发来的一条奇怪的短信，问他们是否应该住在一起，这个问题与她之前对待他们关系的方式完全不符。当他说不时，一场持续多年的辱骂开始了。两天后，凯莉的一位主管收到了一条来自她手机的短信，上面写着：“我不会再回来了。我在堪萨斯找了一份工作。抱歉通知得这么仓促。”
I am sending someone out to you to fill the position. Her name is Shana Golia. A few hours later, Shana Liz Golia filled out an application for a role at the same company where Carrie had worked. As she had no experience in coding or computer programming, her application was unsuccessful. When examining Liz's phone contents, detectives Dodie and Avis found a photo of a woman bound and duct taped in the trunk of a car, the same one that Carrie had emailed to Dave as a threat against Liz. The photo had been snapped on Liz's phone, prompting the detectives to suspect she had taken it of herself. They also found out that the video of Dave's apartment building posted
“我派人去接替这个职位。她叫莎娜·戈利亚。”几个小时后，莎娜·莉兹·戈利亚填写了一份凯莉曾工作过的同一家公司的职位申请表。由于她没有编码或计算机编程方面的经验，她的申请没有成功。在检查莉兹的手机内容时，多蒂和阿维斯侦探发现了一张一名女子被捆绑并用胶带封住嘴关在汽车后备箱里的照片，这正是凯莉发给戴夫作为威胁莉兹的同一张照片。这张照片是用莉兹的手机拍摄的，这促使侦探们怀疑是她自己拍的。他们还发现，以凯莉的名义发布到YouTube上的戴夫公寓大楼的视频，
to YouTube in Carrie's name had actually been uploaded from an IP address registered to Liz's home. Detectives Dodie and Avis informed Carrie's mother Nancy that they suspected Carrie had met with foul play. Relieved that her daughter's case was finally being investigated seriously, Nancy willingly surrendered her cell phone so its contents could be studied as well. Amongst the numerous texts supposedly sent by Carrie was one explaining that she had sold her bedroom furniture and asking Nancy to let the buyer into her home to collect it. A photo of a check for $5,000 was attached. It was signed by Liz Golia. By late 2015, the detectives had accumulated a lot of circumstantial evidence but no definitive
实际上是从注册在莉兹家里的IP地址上传的。多蒂和阿维斯侦探通知凯莉的母亲南希，他们怀疑凯莉遭遇了不测。南希对女儿的案件终于得到认真调查感到欣慰，她自愿交出了手机，以便对其内容进行研究。在凯莉据称发送的众多短信中，有一条解释说她卖掉了卧室家具，并要求南希让买家进入家中取货。附件是一张5000美元的支票照片。支票上签的是莉兹·戈利亚的名字。到2015年底，侦探们积累了大量的间接证据，但没有确切的
answers. Then on December 4, they got a surprise when Liz Golia suddenly walked into the Potawatomi County Sheriff's Department. Liz was there to file a harassment report against Amy Flora, the ex-partner of her former boyfriend Dave Krupa. According to Liz, Amy had been stalking her via Facebook and she now suspected Amy was also responsible for the attacks made in Carrie's father's name. Liz was particularly worried because a pistol that Dave Krupa had acquired for self-defense had suddenly gone missing from his home and she knew that Amy had a key to his property. The detectives requested permission to download Liz's phone once again and encouraged her to contact them if she had any further concerns. A little over 24 hours later, Liz was shot in
答案。然后，在12月4日，当莉兹·戈利亚突然走进波塔瓦塔米县警长办公室时，他们感到很惊讶。莉兹是来对她前男友戴夫·克鲁珀的前伴侣艾米·弗洛拉提出骚扰指控的。据莉兹说，艾米一直在通过Facebook跟踪她，她现在怀疑艾米也应对以凯莉·法弗名义发起的攻击负责。莉兹特别担心，因为戴夫·克鲁珀为自卫而购买的一把手枪突然从他家中失踪，而且她知道艾米有他房产的钥匙。侦探们请求再次下载莉兹的手机数据，并鼓励她在有任何进一步担忧时联系他们。24小时多一点后，莉兹在
the leg while walking in Big Lake Park and pointed to Amy Flora as her attacker. A thorough search of the park turned up no sign of the assailant, while investigators quickly established that Amy Flora had been at home with her children at the time. As bizarre as it seemed, the detectives began to suspect that the shooting had been committed by none other than Liz Golia herself. Back in 2013 when investigators had downloaded Liz's phone contents for the first time, it was assumed she was a victim. For that reason, the police had performed a logical download, only acquiring the data that still remained on the device. Now that they were looking at Liz as a possible suspect, they performed a physical download,
大湖公园散步时腿部中弹，并指认艾米·弗洛拉是袭击者。对公园的彻底搜查没有发现袭击者的踪迹，而调查人员很快确定艾米·弗洛拉在案发时正和孩子们在家中。尽管看起来很离奇，但侦探们开始怀疑枪击事件正是莉兹·戈利亚本人所为。早在2013年，当调查人员第一次下载莉兹的手机内容时，他们认为她是受害者。因此，警方只进行了逻辑下载，只获取了设备上仍然保留的数据。现在他们把莉兹视为可能的嫌疑人，于是进行了物理下载，
which would also give them access to content that had been deleted. As an IT expert trawled through the recovered data, puzzle pieces began to click into place. An app called Texty had been installed by Liz some time ago, then subsequently deleted. It had allowed her to send messages and emails from numerous fake accounts set up under Carrie Father's name. It also enabled Liz to schedule what time she wanted the messages sent, which explained how Dave and Liz had sometimes received texts from Carrie simultaneously, while sitting side by side. Liz had also used a virtual private networks, known as VPNs, to disguise the IP address that her emails were sent from.
这也使他们能够访问已删除的内容。当一名IT专家仔细查看恢复的数据时，拼图开始拼凑起来。一个名为“Texty”的应用程序是莉兹在一段时间前安装的，随后被删除了。它允许她从以凯莉·法弗名义设置的众多虚假账户中发送信息和电子邮件。它还使莉兹能够安排她想要发送信息的时间，这解释了为什么戴夫和莉兹有时会在并排坐着时同时收到凯莉发来的短信。莉兹还使用了被称为VPN的虚拟专用网络来隐藏她发送电子邮件的IP地址。
She had sent tens of thousands of texts and emails to herself, Dave, and any other women whom Dave took an interest in. The IT expert calculated that Liz must have spent between 40 to 50 hours each week impersonating Carrie Father. The investigators decided to put Liz's penchant for sending emails to good use. On December 14, 2015, nine days after the shooting in Big Lake Park, they asked Liz to come in for an interview. Sitting her down in his office, Detective Doty explained that he needed her help. Some human remains had recently been found and they were believed to belong to Carrie Father, but they were still waiting for DNA to confirm the match.
她向自己、戴夫以及戴夫感兴趣的其他女性发送了数万条短信和电子邮件。IT专家计算出，莉兹每周必须花费40到50个小时来冒充凯莉·法弗。调查人员决定利用莉兹喜欢发送电子邮件的习惯。2015年12月14日，在大湖公园枪击事件发生九天后，他们要求莉兹来接受采访。多蒂侦探让她坐在办公室里，解释说他需要她的帮助。最近发现了一些人类遗骸，据信属于凯莉·法弗，但他们仍在等待DNA确认匹配。
Liz listened keenly, as Detective Doty explained that all he needed was some evidence to put his case together, perhaps some evidence that Amy had harmed Carrie. A few days later, emails started trickling into the detective's inbox. Liz was forwarding messages that appeared to have come from Amy Flora, first confessing to shooting Liz, then describing in graphic detail how she had attacked, killed, and disposed of Carrie. As they collated these confessions over the next couple of months, waiting for evidence they could use, the detectives contacted Dave Krupa to share their suspicions with him. Concerned that Liz might decide to attack Amy while they were
莉兹仔细听着，多蒂侦探解释说，他只需要一些证据来整理他的案件，也许是一些艾米伤害了凯莉的证据。几天后，电子邮件开始流入侦探的收件箱。莉兹转发了一些看起来像是来自艾米·弗洛拉的信息，先是承认枪击了莉兹，然后详细描述了她是如何攻击、杀害并处理凯莉的。在接下来的几个月里，当他们整理这些供词并等待可以使用的证据时，侦探们联系了戴夫·克鲁珀，与他分享了他们的怀疑。担心莉兹可能会决定在他们还在整理案件时攻击艾米，
still putting their case together, the detectives told Dave that he should move back in with Amy and their two children for protection. But they also had an ulterior motive in making this suggestion. They hoped that seeing Dave with Amy would push Liz to breaking point. Sure enough, when Liz found out that Dave was staying with his ex, she called Detective Doty demanding to know why Amy hadn't been arrested yet. The detective apologised, explaining that they just didn't have enough evidence tying Amy to Carrie. A few hours later, some emails arrived that contained information only someone who'd been close to Carrie could know. They described a yin-yang tattoo on Carrie's thigh,
侦探们告诉戴夫，他应该搬回去和艾米以及他们的两个孩子住在一起以寻求保护。但他们提出这个建议还有另一个动机。他们希望看到戴夫和艾米在一起会把莉兹逼到崩溃的边缘。果然，当莉兹发现戴夫和他的前任住在一起时，她打电话给多蒂侦探，质问为什么艾米还没有被逮捕。侦探道歉说，他们只是没有足够的证据将艾米与凯莉联系起来。几个小时后，一些电子邮件到达了，其中包含只有与凯莉亲近的人才知道的信息。它们描述了凯莉大腿上的阴阳纹身，
as well as the layout and furnishings of her home. They also specified that Carrie had been attacked in her own Ford Explorer. On February 25, 2016, after identifying Carrie's blood inside her car, the detectives executed a search warrant for Liz Golly's apartment while she was at work. Meanwhile, officers were sent to her workplace to arrest her under the guise of some traffic violations. Because it seemed that Carrie had been attacked at Dave Krupper's home in Nebraska, not Pottawatomie County in Iowa, where she was reported missing, a detective from the Omaha Police Department was brought in to interview Liz. She denied any knowledge of Carrie's whereabouts or involvement in her disappearance and promptly hired a lawyer. At Liz's apartment,
以及她家的布局和陈设。它们还明确指出凯莉是在她自己的福特探险者车内受到攻击的。2016年2月25日，在确认了凯莉车内的血迹后，侦探们在莉兹·戈利亚上班时对她的公寓执行了搜查令。与此同时，警察被派往她的工作地点，以交通违规为由逮捕她。由于凯莉似乎是在内布拉斯加州戴夫·克鲁珀的家中受到攻击，而不是在她被报告失踪的爱荷华州波塔瓦塔米县，因此一名奥马哈警察局的侦探被请来审问莉兹。她否认知道凯莉的下落或参与了她的失踪，并立即聘请了一名律师。在莉兹的公寓里，
police found a black and white shower curtain with a distinctive floral pattern. It matched one that had been bought at a discount store using Carrie's father's debit card several days after she was last seen. They also found a digital camera and a red Sony camcorder that had gone missing from Carrie's home. On the camera was a brief clip that had been filmed on Sunday November 11, 2012, two days before Carrie went missing. The footage showed Carrie filming herself in her house and saying, So, Thursday night, apparently somebody here in the whopping metropolis of Macedonia, Iowa, decided Max's explorer was not the right color. Carrie then took the camera outside and aimed it at her black Ford explorer,
警方发现了一个带有独特花卉图案的黑白浴帘。它与凯莉失踪几天后使用凯莉·法弗的借记卡在折扣店购买的浴帘相符。他们还发现了一台数码相机和一台从凯莉家中失踪的红色索尼摄像机。相机里有一段简短的视频，拍摄于2012年11月11日星期日，即凯莉失踪前两天。录像显示凯莉在家里拍摄自己并说：“所以，周四晚上，显然在爱荷华州马其顿这个大都市的某个人，决定马克斯的探险者颜色不对。”凯莉随后拿着相机走到外面，对准了她的黑色福特探险者，
which she was planning on giving to her son Max. Someone had vandalized the bonnet with white spray paint. Detectives suspected that Liz Golia was responsible for the attack. That wasn't the only evidence that she'd been stalking Carrie in the days before her disappearance. As well as the phone records revealing Liz had called Carrie's home number, two fake Facebook accounts had attempted to add Carrie as a friend right before she went missing. Both claimed to be from Macedonia, the same town as Carrie, but misspelled the town's name in the same distinctive way. Despite the fact that Liz Golia was obsessed with being the only woman in Dave Cooper's life, detectives discovered that she hadn't even been single when they met.
她正计划把它送给她的儿子马克斯。有人用白色喷漆破坏了引擎盖。侦探们怀疑莉兹·戈利亚应对这次袭击负责。这并不是她失踪前几天跟踪凯莉的唯一证据。除了电话记录显示莉兹曾拨打凯莉的家庭电话外，两个虚假的Facebook账户在凯莉失踪前试图加她为好友。两者都声称来自马其顿，即凯莉所在的城镇，但以同样独特的方式拼错了城镇名称。尽管莉兹·戈利亚痴迷于成为戴夫·克鲁珀生命中唯一的女性，但侦探们发现，他们在见面时她甚至不是单身。
In 2010, Liz started dating a man named Eric, not his real name. Eric was under the impression that the two were exclusive and was a supportive partner to Liz. He helped her out financially, assisted with looking after her two children, and invited them all to move in with him when Liz was evicted from her house in 2013. When Liz's home burnt down in August of that year, it coincided with a period when she and Dave Cooper weren't seeing each other. Every time Dave's attention drifted from Liz, an increase in Carrie's stalking activity or an attack against Liz would follow. She and the children were already living with Eric when her house was set on fire.
2010年，莉兹开始与一名叫埃里克（化名）的男子约会。埃里克认为两人是排他的，并且是莉兹的支持性伴侣。他在经济上帮助她，协助照顾她的两个孩子，并在2013年莉兹被赶出家门时邀请他们全家搬去和他住。当莉兹的家在同年8月被烧毁时，这恰逢她和戴夫·克鲁珀没有见面的时期。每当戴夫的注意力从莉兹身上转移时，凯莉的跟踪活动或对莉兹的攻击就会随之增加。当她的房子被纵火时，她和孩子们已经和埃里克住在一起了。
Nothing of value was lost in the blaze with the exception of Liz's four pets, which included two small dogs that Eric had paid for. A couple of months after Carrie's father disappeared, Eric had started receiving text messages and emails from someone named Carrie, who claimed to know Liz. When he asked Liz about the matter, she confirmed that Carrie was her friend. Eric eventually grew tired of Liz, who was cruel and made fun of him behind his back. He ended their relationship and she moved out of his house at the end of 2015, around the same time that she was shot. While Liz was living under Eric's roof,
火灾中没有损失任何有价值的东西，除了莉兹的四只宠物，其中包括埃里克花钱买的两只小狗。在凯莉·法弗失踪几个月后，埃里克开始收到来自一个叫凯莉的人的短信和电子邮件，她声称认识莉兹。当他问莉兹这件事时，她证实凯莉是她的朋友。埃里克最终厌倦了莉兹，她很残忍，在背后取笑他。他结束了他们的关系，她在2015年底搬出了他的房子，大约在她中枪的同一时间。当莉兹住在埃里克的屋檐下时，
she used his Wi-Fi and some of his electronic devices. As it happened, Eric was employed by Pottawatomie County's IT department and reported to the same expert who had investigated Liz's phone data. This meant his computer system was linked to the county's network and law enforcement could access long-term records of his household's internet activity. Detectives were able to strengthen their case against Liz by tracing exactly what she had done online while connected to Eric's Wi-Fi. Liz Golia was charged with first-degree murder on Tuesday, December 27, 2016. Another charge of second-degree arson was added for the crime of burning down her own home.
她使用了他的Wi-Fi和一些电子设备。碰巧的是，埃里克受雇于波塔瓦塔米县的IT部门，并向调查莉兹手机数据的同一位专家汇报工作。这意味着他的计算机系统与县的网络相连，执法部门可以访问他家庭互联网活动的长期记录。侦探们通过追踪她在连接到埃里克的Wi-Fi时在网上所做的一切，加强了对莉兹的指控。莉兹·戈利亚于2016年12月27日星期二被控一级谋杀罪。由于纵火烧毁自己的家，她又被加控了一项二级纵火罪。
Her lawyer publicly defended Liz in the press, explaining that without Carrie Farve's body, investigators really had no proof that she wasn't still alive somewhere. Investigators had repeatedly asked Dave Krupper if he had any additional electronic devices that they could look at for evidence, but he couldn't think of any. Then, in early 2017, he suddenly remembered that he had a tablet computer stashed away in storage which Liz had sometimes used while the two were dating. Dave retrieved the tablet and police found a micro-SD memory card inside, which had also been used in Liz's cell phone. The card had been wiped, but through meticulous work, the department's IT expert was able to recover thousands of deleted
她的律师在媒体上公开为莉兹辩护，解释说如果没有凯莉·法弗的尸体，调查人员真的没有证据证明她没有在某个地方还活着。调查人员曾多次询问戴夫·克鲁珀是否有任何额外的电子设备可以供他们查看证据，但他想不起来。然后，在2017年初，他突然想起他有一个存放在仓库里的平板电脑，莉兹在两人约会时有时会使用。戴夫取回了平板电脑，警方在里面发现了一张微型SD存储卡，它也曾在莉兹的手机中使用过。这张卡已被擦除，但通过细致的工作，该部门的IT专家得以恢复了数千张已删除的
photographs that had once been stored there. He scrolled through photo after photo of Liz. Among the selfies and pictures of her children, he reached some images that were completely different in tone. Several showed a blue and gray tarp spread out over an unseen object. Another showed what looked like skin with a yin-yang symbol on it. Then, there was a picture of some Chinese characters inked onto what looked like reddish-colored flesh. A forensic expert confirmed that the photograph was of a human foot in the process of decomposition. When investigators checked with Carrie Farve's mother, she told them that Carrie had the Chinese word for mother tattooed on her left foot. It was a perfect match to the characters shown in the photo.
曾经存储在那里的照片。他滚动浏览了一张又一张莉兹的照片。在自拍和她孩子的照片中，他看到了一些基调完全不同的图像。几张照片显示一块蓝色和灰色的防水布铺在一个看不见的物体上。另一张显示看起来像皮肤的东西，上面有一个阴阳符号。然后，有一张照片显示一些中文汉字印在看起来像红色的肉上。法医专家证实，这张照片是一只处于腐烂过程中的人脚。当调查人员与凯莉·法弗的母亲核实时，她告诉他们，凯莉的左脚上纹有中文“母亲”二字。这与照片中显示的汉字完全吻合。
Detectives later told the ABC television program 2020 how disturbing they'd found the image. To them, it seemed like a trophy. It was also the crucial piece of evidence that they needed to prove their case. When the defense found out about the evidence, Liz Golia waved her right to a jury trial, instead opting for a bench trial in which a judge would decide her fate. Her lawyer presented no evidence, and Liz Golia did not testify. Meanwhile, the prosecution's case was extensive, relying on numerous witnesses and mountains of evidence, much of it relating to Liz's online activities. On Wednesday, May 24, 2017, Shana Elizabeth Golia was found guilty on both counts. She was sentenced to life imprisonment for Carrie's murder and 18 to 20 years for the arson,
侦探们后来告诉美国广播公司电视节目《2020》，他们发现这张照片有多令人不安。对他们来说，这看起来像是一个战利品。这也是他们证明案件所需的关键证据。当辩方发现这一证据时，莉兹·戈利亚放弃了陪审团审判的权利，转而选择由法官决定她命运的法官审判。她的律师没有提供任何证据，莉兹·戈利亚也没有作证。与此同时，检方的案件非常广泛，依赖于众多的证人和大量的证据，其中大部分与莉兹的在线活动有关。2017年5月24日星期三，莎娜·伊丽莎白·戈利亚被判两项罪名成立。她因谋杀凯莉被判终身监禁，因纵火罪被判18至20年监禁，
with the sentences to run consecutively. While Carrie's loved ones celebrated upon hearing the verdict, Liz Golia turned red and closed her eyes as she was escorted from the courtroom. In 2020, author Leslie Rule, the daughter of famed true crime writer Anne Rule, published a book about the case titled A Tangled Web. In researching Liz Golia's background and early life, Rule made some troubling discoveries. After losing her entire family at a very young age and experiencing a difficult upbringing in the foster care system, Liz married and was divorced by age 22. At 23, she gave birth to her first child, a boy she named Cody Golia. Cody cried a lot, and members of his extended family thought he seemed like an extremely
刑期连续执行。当凯莉的亲人在听到判决时欢呼雀跃时，莉兹·戈利亚在被带离法庭时脸色发红，闭上了眼睛。2020年，著名真实犯罪作家安·鲁尔的女儿、作家莱斯利·鲁尔出版了一本关于此案的书，名为《纠缠的网》。在研究莉兹·戈利亚的背景和早年生活时，鲁尔有一些令人不安的发现。在很小的时候失去整个家庭并在寄养系统中经历了艰难的成长过程后，莉兹在22岁时结婚并离婚。23岁时，她生下了第一个孩子，一个她取名为科迪·戈利亚的男孩。科迪哭得很厉害，他的大家庭成员认为他看起来像是一个极其
unhappy baby. But Liz said he was just colicky. One morning, Liz's 21-year-old boyfriend Neil Munson, who wasn't Cody's father, was looking after a five-month-old Cody while Liz was at work. Neil's mother, Golia, was helping him and noticed how strangely quiet Cody was. He remained that way for the entire day. At around 5pm, Golia went to check on Cody and was horrified to discover he wasn't breathing. An ambulance was called and Cody was rushed to hospital, but he was pronounced dead shortly after. The cause of death was found to be a serious brain injury caused by Cody being forcefully shaken. Neil Munson, who had an intellectual disability, was grilled by investigators for hours. While he admitted to sometimes playfully
不快乐的婴儿。但莉兹说他只是肠绞痛。一天早上，莉兹21岁的男友尼尔·曼森（不是科迪的父亲）在莉兹上班时照顾五个月大的科迪。尼尔的母亲戈利亚在帮他，注意到科迪安静得有些反常。他整天都保持那样。下午5点左右，戈利亚去查看科迪，惊恐地发现他没有呼吸了。救护车被叫来，科迪被紧急送往医院，但不久后被宣布死亡。死因被发现是科迪被用力摇晃造成的严重脑损伤。有智力障碍的尼尔·曼森被调查人员审问了几个小时。虽然他承认有时会顽皮地
throwing Cody in the air, he said that the baby had always laughed and enjoyed the game. As the officers continued to press him, Neil acknowledged that he might have thrown Cody higher than usual that day. Neil Munson was eventually charged with killing Cody. But not everyone was convinced that Neil was responsible. When Neil's mother, Golia, realized how sick Cody was, she asked Neil if anything strange had happened recently. He'd mentioned that Liz had called him at work the previous night and told him to hurry home because she dropped the baby. Multiple people in Liz's life, including Cody's father, suspected that she had something to do with the infant's death. She seemed unusually
把科迪扔向空中，但他表示婴儿总是笑得很开心，很喜欢这个游戏。随着警官们继续施压，尼尔承认他那天可能把科迪扔得比平时高。尼尔·曼森最终被控杀害科迪。但并非所有人都相信尼尔是罪魁祸首。当尼尔的母亲戈利亚意识到科迪病得有多重时，她问尼尔最近是否发生了什么奇怪的事情。他提到莉兹前一天晚上在工作时给他打电话，让他赶快回家，因为她把孩子摔了。莉兹生活中的多个人，包括科迪的父亲，都怀疑她与婴儿的死亡有关。她在科迪死后的几天里显得异常
cheerful in the days after Cody died. At Neil's trial, he pleaded guilty after a series of incriminating letters emerged that he had supposedly sent to Liz from prison. Dramatic with overwritten, flowery prose, the letters declared Neil's undying love for Liz and asked her to say she'd dropped Cody in order to, quote, set me free. Neil never denied writing the letters, but those close to him believed they were far beyond his capabilities as a writer. Author Leslie Rule has attempted to track down the original letters to study their handwriting, pointing out that Liz Golia is now on the record as someone known to forge confessions in another person's name.
开朗。在尼尔的审判中，在一系列据称是他从监狱寄给莉兹的煽动性信件出现后，他认罪了。这些信件用夸张、华丽的辞藻写成，表达了尼尔对莉兹永恒的爱，并要求她说她是把科迪摔了，以便“让我自由”。尼尔从未否认写过这些信，但那些了解他的人认为这些信远超出了他作为作家的能力。作家莱斯利·鲁尔试图找到原始信件来研究它们的笔迹，指出莉兹·戈利亚现在是有记录的以他人名义伪造供词的人。
So far, Rule has been unable to find them. Neil Munson was paroled after eight and a half years. He is now a father of two and father of two, and his family staunchly believes in his innocence. For years, Dave Krupper believed he was being stalked by Carrie Farver, a woman who he'd felt connected to from the moment they met. His initial affection for Carrie had turned to hatred before he finally learnt the truth. Upon realising Liz was behind it all, some things finally started to make sense. Dave recalled one evening he'd returned home late from a local bar and spotted Liz in the dark, army crawling on the ground away from his apartment.
到目前为止，鲁尔还没能找到它们。尼尔·曼森在服刑八年半后获得假释。他现在是两个孩子的父亲，他的家人坚定地相信他是无辜的。多年来，戴夫·克鲁珀一直认为自己被凯莉·法弗跟踪，这个女人让他从见面那一刻起就感到有联系。他对凯莉最初的爱慕变成了仇恨，直到他最终得知了真相。在意识到莉兹是这一切的幕后黑手后，一些事情终于开始说得通了。戴夫回忆起一天晚上，他从当地一家酒吧很晚回家，在黑暗中看到莉兹在地上爬行，远离他的公寓。
He called out to her, but she ignored him as she slithered away into the night. As soon as he entered his home, he received a flurry of text from Liz, apologising and explaining that she was drunk and had no idea what she was doing. The thought that Carrie lost her life because she met him has been too painful for Dave Krupper to process and has left him wracked with guilt. Dave has given numerous interviews about his experiences with Liz, explaining to author Leslie Rule that he plans on appearing in every television program that Nancy Rainey does so he can help her share Carrie's story. Nancy has said Dave is a victim who, just like her daughter, was in the wrong place at the wrong
他叫她，但她滑入夜色中时无视了他。他一进家门，就收到莉兹发来的一连串短信，道歉并解释说她喝醉了，不知道自己在做什么。凯莉因为遇见他而失去生命的想法对戴夫·克鲁珀来说太痛苦了，无法承受，这让他备受内疚的折磨。戴夫就他与莉兹的经历接受了多次采访，向作家莱斯利·鲁尔解释说，他计划出现在南希·雷尼参加的每一个电视节目中，这样他就可以帮助她分享凯莉的故事。南希说戴夫是一个受害者，就像她的女儿一样，在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。
time. She knows that Carrie would want Dave to forgive himself. Carrie's son Max is now at university and is following her example by studying computer science. A scholarship in Carrie's name has also been established at Iowa Western Community College, her former school, as a way of keeping Carrie's legacy of kindness alive. The years Carrie's loved ones were tormented by the knowledge that something terrible had happened to her and whoever was responsible was taunting them. Although they doubted Carrie could still be alive, Liz Gollia's messages sometimes made it impossible to give up hope. One time, Nancy was told Carrie was waiting for her at a homeless shelter in Omaha.
她知道凯莉会希望戴夫原谅自己。凯莉的儿子马克斯现在正在上大学，并追随她的榜样学习计算机科学。一个以凯莉名字命名的奖学金也已在她的母校爱荷华西部社区学院设立，作为保持凯莉善良遗产的一种方式。多年来，凯莉的亲人一直被某种可怕的事情发生在她身上，而肇事者在嘲弄他们的事实所折磨。虽然他们怀疑凯莉是否还活着，但莉兹·戈利亚的信息有时让他们无法放弃希望。有一次，南希被告知凯莉在奥马哈的一家收容所等她。
Nancy had rushed to the shelter, overjoyed at the thought of seeing her daughter again, but when she arrived, she was told no one there had seen Carrie. In an interview with the Omaha World Herald newspaper, Nancy shared Carrie's hopes for how her life would be celebrated after her passing. She wanted to be cremated and thrown to the wind. Unfortunately, Nancy may never be able to do this for her daughter. While pretending to be Amy, Liz Gollia claimed she burned Carrie's remains then threw them in the garbage. If this is true, it would be impossible for authorities to recover them. Although Nancy was upset that she couldn't fulfill Carrie's wish,
南希冲向收容所，想到能再次见到女儿欣喜若狂，但当她到达时，被告知那里没有人见过凯莉。在接受《奥马哈世界先驱报》采访时，南希分享了凯莉对她去世后生活如何庆祝的希望。她想被火化并撒向风中。不幸的是，南希可能永远无法为她的女儿做到这一点。在假装是艾米时，莉兹·戈利亚声称她烧毁了凯莉的遗体，然后把它们扔进了垃圾桶。如果这是真的，当局将不可能找回它们。虽然南希对无法实现凯莉的愿望感到难过，
she was thinking of holding a celebration in her honor, stating, she would have wanted a party and a big gathering. She loved life. I just wish she could have had more of it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她正考虑为她举行庆祝活动，并说：“她会想要一个派对和大型聚会。她热爱生活。我只是希望她能拥有更多。”本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。